hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast file linked alkylation for the
metabolic sequencing of RNA and judy or
oracle a brutes and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by lab Ruth
sponsored by Lexington Lexington is a
transcriptomics and next-generation
sequencing company focusing on the
development of technologies for complete
transcriptome sequencing if portfolio
includes innovative molecular biology
tips software and services for RNA seek
for more visit WWE accident comm so we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can
you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window if
you have any technical problems viewing
or sharing this presentation please
click on the support button to talk
right of your presentation window or
submit your problem through the green
2n8 button lower left I would now like
to introduce today's speaker Stefan L
Amira's PhD
group leader of the Institute of
molecular biotechnology in Vienna
Austria dr. Ramirez acquired his
master's degree in biology at the
friedrich alexander university Erling in
nuremberg he did his PhD thesis in the
lab of rene Schroder at the Max s
carrots laboratories of the University
of Vienna there dr. Ramirez performed
the first in-depth enzymatic
characterization of the human RNA
interference effector complex next was a
postdoc with Philip Seymour at the
University of Massachusetts Medical
School where he focused on the small RNA
mediated gene regulation in flies and
mammals
dr. Amira's started his own lab in 2012
at the Institute of molecular
biotechnology in Vienna his lab
investigates the mechanism and biology
post transcriptional gene regulation
supported by the European Research
Council through an e rc starting grant
dr. Amira is an elected young
member of the Austrian Academy of
Sciences and recently selected M Bo
Young Investigator
his complete bio is shown on the
labyrinth website I will now turn it
over to dr. Ramirez for his presentation
thank you very much Judy so today I
would like to introduce you to a novel
gene expression profiling protocol that
we have developed at the Institute of
molecular biotechnology
it's the Vienna violence in Austria
which ever not as I mentioned to the
analysis of standards high throughput
RNA sequencing approaches and this is
the dimension of time which needs to
gain insights into how gene expression
programs are actually established in
order to study the regulation of gene
expression at the transcriptional as
well as at the post transcriptional
level so for cells to fulfill their
biological role as they give rise to the
different cell types in the context of
tissues and organs of a multicellular
organism they need to mount specific
gene expression profiles and failure to
do so can result in severe diseases such
as cancer so gene expression profiling
by high-throughput sequencing has really
revolutionized the way we can associate
distinct gene expression profiles to
cellular states thereby providing
mechanistic entry points to
understanding the basis of physiological
as well as part of the geological
processes at the molecular level however
currently available technologies for the
high-throughput profiling of gene
expression really only take a snapshot
of the relative abundance of any given
transcript at a given time point inside
cells what they don't do is to provide
us with information on how this gene
expression profile is actually
established which means the rate at
which each individual transcript is
produced and the rate at which it is
degraded but it is actually this
information that provides us with
insights into how each transcript is
regulated both a transcriptional level
which is determined by a combinatorial
action of promoters enhancers associated
transcription factors
chromatin length game - just name a few
as well is that the post transcriptional
level which defines transcript abilities
as determined by our binding proteins
RNA modifications small RNAs are any
structure codon usage and many more now
because of the importance of
understanding the molecular basis for
gene regulation several approaches have
been developed to globally address the
kinetics of gene expression at the
genomic scale so I start the genome-wide
analysis of NASA sent RNA is engaged
with transcriptionally active RNA
polymerase by high-throughput sequencing
such as through approaches like agro
seek Pro seek or net seek represent
powerful methods to investigate the
transcriptional activity despite the
utility these approaches are really
technically challenging and not readily
scalable and they do not discriminate
functional RNA molecules that are fully
processed from transcriptional
byproducts on the other hand RNA DK
rates are commonly determined by the
overly interfering with RNA polymerase
followed by the relative quantification
of RNA molecules over time they are due
to the global loss of RNAs the
quantification of absolute already hot
light remains imprecise furthermore
inhibiting polymerase 2 activity
compromises cell viability and induces
major stress responses triggering
secondary effects including the selected
stabilization of specific transcripts
now in principle metabolic RNA labeling
approaches that employs the
incorporation of nucleoside analogues in
able to track RNA species all the time
without interfering with cellular
integrity among these fourth I origin is
probably the most widely used nucleotide
and a lot to study the dynamics of RNA
expression because it is readily
imported into many methods to on sales
by équilibre nucleotide transporters and
provides unique physical chemical
properties for Silas about specific
reactivity and affinity which enables
for example the biochemical separation
by reversible dial termination and
such approaches have been successfully
applied to cultured cells of diverse
biological origin and across many
species through methods such as s Foley
who seek or more recently TTC however
like any biochemical separation methods
the underlying protocols are the Boreas
require ample starting material and
typically encounter the problem of low
signal to noise performance in part
because of limited palatalization
efficiencies and again such strategies
are really not readily scalable so the
more the analysis of labor's are in
transcripts by biochemical fractionation
followed by sequencing required
extensive controls so when new really
needs to sequence three samples protein
points the inputs the fractionated RNA
as well as the flow through in order to
provide integrative insights into gene
expression dynamics and it fails to
report global effects until unless as
backing strategies are applied now to
overcome these limitations for measuring
the intracellular kinetics of RNA
transcription and turnover we have
developed another protocol which we
refer to as filings alkylations for the
metabolic sequencing of RNA or in short
slanting now how does slam seek work so
we employ the well-established
metabolic labeling strategy employing
the nucleotide analog for ty you reading
which as I've mentioned is readily taken
up by cultured cells and incorporated
into newly transcribed RNA so total RNA
is then prepared as given time points
after labeling and instead of
biochemical fractionation slam seek
employs a file specific chemical
modification strategy to listen we use
your acetamide which is which
specifically reacts with a primary style
group of present in photo jordan but not
any other naturally-occurring nucleotide
this oxidation reaction modulates the
base pairing capacity of porta jordan so
that when RNA is afterwards subjected to
cDNA library preparation for
high-throughput
wenting reverse transcriptase will miss
incorporate in this process of going
across
chemically modified forth ie reading
which upon high throughput sequencing
enables 2,000 attica Li detect for tally
you read in labor transcripts by T to
see conversions
I would like what I would like to do in
this webinar is to show you how slam
seek enables cost-effective insights
into intra cellular RNA kinetics and a
brilliant unprecedented accessibility
efficiency and scalability and therefore
represent a powerful tool for the
dissection of fundamental biological
mechanisms that control gene expression
but before I do so I would like to
highlight people in the lab who really
established slam seek and this project
was laughs and outstanding postdoc in
the lab Veronica here so supportive of
each issued and Brian Wright was a bath
is a PhD student was involved in some of
the informatics work and although I will
not go into detail in this presentation
about the paramedics backgrounds in
analyzing the data would like to
highlight two very gifted mathematician
who developed a sophisticated bomb
phonetics pipeline that enables the
rapid analysis of slam seek datasets and
even for bench scientists that is to be
a snowman from the Institute of
molecular pathology and the tubular as
well as a phil' oppression either from
anthem hazard at lab at MacLaren's
laboratories both located at the Vienna
BioCenter now I would like to use the
next couple of slides in order to give
you to guide you through the key steps
of the santak protocol and the
experiments we have performed to
validate the chemistry and the
nucleotide conversion readout I will
then introduce you briefly into the
library preparation methods we are
employing and the important technical
considerations that need to be taken
into account when starting a slanting
experiment and then in the end I would
like to show you briefly how we employ
slam seek in mouse embryonic stem cells
to get insights into
the regulation of the reportedly
associated gene expression at the
transcriptional and post transcriptional
level now first we have to validate the
key steps of the slanted protocol in
order to ensure that this is a highly
quantitative method first in order to
provide rapid and direct experimental
access to metabolically labeled RNA by
sequencing we employed a chemical
derivatives Asian approach 4/4 I'll you
reading
to this end we employ the primary style
reactive compounds your acetamide which
covalently attaches a carboxy amino
methyl group to fourth i you reading by
nucleophilic substitution we confirm the
quantitative alkylation of both IU
reading by two approaches first by
spectrophotometry where we monitor the
shift in the characteristic absorbance
spectrum of four tell you from 335
nanometers as shown in the left to 297
nanometers upon Eurostat a light
directed alkylation and found that under
optimal reaction conditions absorbance
appear in a 35 nanometer decreased 54
compared to untreated for 30 euros for
are you restarting in close to complete
alkylation within 15 minutes and we
validated these results by mass
spectrometer from a tree which confirmed
kill to complete their participation
efficiencies now in a second important
points the quantitative identification
of four value by sequencing presumes
that reverse transcriptase passes
calculated for value relatives without
struggle we therefore determine the
effect of both value alkylation on RT
processivity in primary extension assays
using
radioactively-labeled primer and
synthetic RNA that contains a single
photon you reading at a defined position
so we we determine this before and after
treatment with your acetamide and then
assess the products of the reverse
friends
and possible drop of signal by
high-resolution gel electrophoresis when
we zoom into the to the region where the
fault is
present compared to the control then
compared to an identical ironing without
fourth IU incorporation and normalized
to Peck background proper signal we did
not observe a significant effect of
portal alkylation on RT processivity
when using any of three different
commercially available reverse
transcriptase as shown by the
quantification in the left so to
evaluate the effect of our tire equation
on our t directed nucleotide
incorporation we isolated the
full-length products of prime extension
reactions PCR amplified the cDNA and
subjected libraries to a high throughput
sequencing again we used the non for ty
you written labeled synthetic are near
the control and found the treatment of
RNA with your settlement has no adverse
effect on mutation rates of any given
nucleotide in the control illegal as
shown in the quantifications to the left
while the presence of what are you in a
control RNA prompted a constant 10 to
11% of T to see conversions as seen at
position 9 this is a present and this is
presumably due to base pairing
variations of author Utah Turner's what
are your alkylation increased t2z
conversions by 8.54 resulting in a in a
conversion rate of greater than 94% so
together with a chemical modification
efficiency that i've showed before we
computed that your satellite treatment
followed by reverse transcription
specifically identified both iu in
corporations in RNA at single nucleotide
resolution by sequencing and an
efficiency of greater than 90% now to
combine slam sync with an rapid
robust and cost-effective high
throughput artist sequencing strategy we
employed the mRNA cerebrum and
sequencing method called quantity
there's just very briefly the way
through from mRNA sequencing
is the total RNA and is subject is the
reverse transcription using an anchor to
liquidity primer which primes the
reverse transcription at the beginning
of a poly a tail of already 2
transcripts after the reverse
transcription RNA is removed and second
strand synthesis is directed by a
randomized illegal containing an adapter
and after purification and BCI of
duplication these libraries can be hit
as subjected but to have to put
sequencing using the Illumina platform
now this sequencing approach has several
key advantages which I will briefly go
through first of all it uses total RNA
as inputs there but does not require
prior Fourier enrichment or rRNA
depletion the library preparation
follows a robust and rapid workflow
which enables to generate sequencing
ready libraries in less than 5 hours and
this can be readily gains through
automated library preparation protocols
it provides exceptional strand
specificity and it identifies a
transcript three prime ends which
enables to de novo annotate transcript
ends which is highly recommended and we
have developed an algorithm to do this
from one seat theater that for which you
find the reference indicated in the
respective point it also enables to do a
simple gene counting so that means at
just one fragment per transcript is
produced
therefore normalization to team length
is obsolete and the lower library
complexity here further enables to do
less deep sequencing and therefore
enable Costas cost-saving multiplexing
it also facilitates the Baron thematic
analysis because Junction detection is
not required because reads are generated
from the transcripts at the three prime
end where nearly no junctions are
located and finally at Lansing specific
advantage is that at the high coverage
of mRNAs 3 Prem taksasila tates the
calling of TC conversions particularly
because amplicons derives from three
prime utrs
which are inherently
you which of course also some
limitations it is of course restricted
to polyadenylated army species so
therefore article to the transcript and
it does not provide information on slice
isoforms or a transcript start size now
we have perform validations of Quantic
across across close to a hundred
libraries meanwhile mostly in mouth
several expenses and the meta-analysis
as you can see here shows a clear
enrichment of the fragment within an
around 250 nucleotides window upstream
of a more annotated Emily's reprimands
in comparison of Quantic signal shows an
overall height and significant
correlation with standard RNA sequencing
approaches across more than 17,000
transcripts and most importantly one
seat delivers highly reproducible
reserves across biological replicates
now having spent this detour on the
library preparation protocols I would
like to now go into some sanity checks
that we highly recommend to implement
before starting an antique experiment to
be sure that one is working on the
unfiltered conditions and in an
effective way
first of all we highly recommend to
titrate for tie you into the cell type
of interest to determine toxic effects
which typically set in a very high
fatality concentration presumably
because the new scenario for SIA results
in are already biogenesis defects that
have been reported before with therefore
typically work at concentrations far
below the is the 50 and recommended an
ideal concentration the EC 10 value as
unreasonable upper limit now because the
uptake of forced are you can vary quite
substantially between different cell
types because we consider this to be an
essential first step in setting up this
method and second before going into
library preparations to be recommend to
test uptake or for tie you within any
corporation into RNA which can be
rapidly assess after total are any
preparation in single nuclear site
followed by HPLC analysis as previously
described as shown in the citation for
this we recommend to label the
saturation that means for 12 to 24 hours
because the majority of transcripts
total RNA consists of very stable
non-coding RNA species including our RNA
and TR so the test is flimsy enables us
to quantify for thiolated
RNA pol ii transcripts in a mouse
embryonic stem cells we subjected
themselves to four value labeling for 24
hours and prepares one seed libraries
after chemical modification using the
slam seek protocol the whole library
preparation is extraordinarily efficient
and takes less than five hours including
the chemical modification step how do
that we just look like you can see a
genome browser screenshots of a
particular gene called 328 working where
we compare regular RNA seeks a whole
transcript RNA sequencing approach in
the top a cap seek a track in the middle
which marks the transcript 5mm in one
seat on the bottom which shows a pilot
of reads at the transcript 3 prime end
as expected when we zoom into this
region and inspect the underlying
subset of the underlying weeds we
observe a low mutation frequency in
samples generated from untreated cells
and after metabolic labeling for 24
hours followed by slam seek we observe a
strong accumulation of TC conversion
containing reads so meta analysis showed
that these keys in mutations distribute
evenly across the area covered by
sequencing using one seek and when we
compare all possible mutation
frequencies we find that mutations are
found below the sequencing every
reported four Illumina technology which
is 0.1 percent and only up our metabolic
labeling with both is shown on the right
we observe a statistically significant
increase only in CC conversions but not
any other nucleotide conversion notes
Erb leads the broken y-axis to interpret
the full range of the signal which spans
two orders of magnitude now together
these analysis
firmness lamzy provides a robust access
to 4,000 corporation events in MRNA
following fourth item metabolic RNA
labeling in cultured cells now as
mentioned in the introduction
steady-state expression gene expression
is dictated by the relative
contributions of the rate of
transcription and RNA DK to parameters
that can not be derived from standard
RNA sequencing approaches now to test if
slam seat provides quantitative access
to the polyadenylated transcriptional
output we subjected mouse embryonic stem
cells to a short 45 minute fourth Ayub
pulse labeling followed by total RNA
extraction methylation and mRNAs
reprimand library preparation we first
approximately the number of molecules
that were made within the short time
frame of labeling by inspecting
background errors abstracted T's T to
see conversion containing reads for
individual transcripts as displayed here
indeed initially infection of these
selected transcripts with comparable
state sector balance revealed that
transcript specific differences in the
number of regarded T series while high
levels of T to see conversions were
recovered for the embryonic stem cells
specific transcription factor sox2 and
the inherently unstable primary micro
need transcript derived from the mere -
90 to 95 clever the housekeeping
transcript gap th associated with fewer
T seaweed presumably because it's
accumulation does not require high
transcriptional output but instead
relies on high transcripts turbidity now
a transcriptional output via RNA
polymerase 2 is regulated regulated by
transcription factors the sciences
acting regulatory elements known as it
hands us to recruit co-activators and
po2 to target genes
so in multimeric stem cells the
pluripotency stage is largely governed
by a small number of master
transcription factors including opt for
Sox tool and Nano which drive the
expression of target genes NASA
blue necessary to maintain the embryonic
stem cell state and then positively
regulate their own promoters forming an
interconnected auto-regulatory loop now
transcriptional output measurements
battle-axes lambdak reveals that opt for
stocks to nano target genes shown in
blue and red produced overall a larger
amount of t2c conversion containing
reads in the 4th oil plants experiment
confirming their high transcriptional
activity now to connect these
observations to molecular principles of
transcriptional gene regulation we
correlated the measures and Krypton
output to proximal enhancer low side
which can be classified by their
association with the transcription
factors or force of tools in an oak
because it's OS n enhancers as displayed
here this has previously been described
by a chip seek approaches now hence
groups derived from approximately 2000
expressed genes with proximal of for
socks tuna dog occupancy shown in as OS
n produced significantly higher levels
of Tweety to see conversion contain
agreed-upon path labeling when compared
to close to 5,000 genes without proximal
upwards of two nano enhancers shown as
no a subset of enhancers in other many
sensors were previously described from a
race of concatenated regulatory elements
also known as super and the hunters of
strong analysis here david sse with
unusually strong accumulation of
transcriptional activators specifically
mediated in fact the 150 genes around
150 G's in the proximity of such strong
enhancers exhibited the highest
transcriptional output significantly
offset from typically enhancers in our
slam seek measurement now together with
effects that we detected a significant
correlation between transcription output
measurements determined by semantic and
assertive methods like for example
grossy these data confirm that short for
thew pals labeling in common
with slam Zeke and Emily reprimands
sequencing it needs to uncouple the
immediate transcription of the output
from stability effects to directly
measure the functional fall to derived
transcriptional activity at the genomics
gate the method therefore provides a
rapid and scalable approach to study
transcriptional gene regulatory circuits
in mammalian cells now in the last part
I would like to illustrate how slam Z
can be employed for the direct
measurement of mRNA transcript
stabilities now to address this we
subjected mouse embryonic stem cells to
4th iu metabolic labeling for 24 hours
followed by a washout and chase using
non file containing urea and prepared
total rnase at various time points along
the chase now total RNA was again
subjected to alkylation as described
before and mrna 3 prevent sequencing so
first again let's inspect candidate
genes here you can see a genome browser
coverage track for four different genes
with assuming two their three prime ends
across the whole time course now when we
inspect all reads that means the TC
conversion containing and non containing
leads we have served that steady state
gene expression stays constant for these
individual transcripts across the whole
time course which is what we would
expect if you were working under
unperturbed conditions and it is also
confirmed globally when comparing steady
state expression will be along the
tankers now in contrast TC conversion
containing reads shown in red here
decreased over time in a transcript
specific manner which is independent of
the steady state abundance of each
transcript after calculating the
background substracted new content and
coverage normalized TC conversion rate
for each transcript at every time point
relative to the onset of the positive of
the JS we observed that conversion rate
fit well to a single exponential detail
ethics enabling the robust determination
of polyadenylated transcript archives
and expected earlier stabilities
differed by more than one order of
magnitudes among individual transcripts
a very short half-life post for example
for the primary micronic transcripts of
the derived from the mutant 90 to 95
cluster which has a half-life of less
than one hour most certainly because it
is subjected to rapid co-transcriptional
processing by the artist 3 hands and
russia in the nucleus now but by fitting
the data to 8,000 foreigners transcripts
with a steady-state expression about a
certain cutoff to a single exponential
decay kinetics we determined the medium
M already have five of three point nine
hours corresponding to a cell cycle
normal at half-life of four point three
hours which fall within the range of
previously determined immodest
activities in mammalian cells ranging in
million half-life from between three and
ten hours depending on cell type and
experimental technique now because we
use mRNA three prime and sequencing we
can even assign transcript half-life to
each of the three prime isoforms of any
given gene locus as illustrated here for
this gene our FRP one where we can see a
more than five four difference in mrna
three prime eyes of stability the screen
shot also illustrates the importance of
reevaluating gene annotations with
respect to the annotated three permanent
because many genes produce
cell type-specific variants which
warranty know that notation here is
another example for the gene text two
six one which produces three three prime
x albums whether longer whether two
longer variants and our half is stable
when compared to the shorter and the
longest I perform even extends beyond
the refseq annotation but shows clear
connectivity to the upstream
transcription unit when inspecting whole
transcript derived artist signals are
shown on the very top
now previous investigations of mRNA
stability proposed a close relationship
between transcript specific mRNA
half-life and the encoded physiological
function or other when we rank the more
than 6000 examine transcripts for which
how that was determined at high accuracy
according to their relative stability
and performed gene ontology analysis for
the 10% most or least stable mRNAs
transcripts with short half-life
significantly enriched for regulators of
pol to dependent transcription while
stable mRNAs from red associated with
the goal terms translation respiratory
electron transport and oxidative
phosphorylation so this means that
transcripts encoding proteins with
housekeeping functions such as protein
synthesis or respiration tend to decay
at low rates which perhaps reflects the
evolutionary adaptation to energy
constraints so an mRNA that is needed
all the time is rendered stable in order
to not have to produce it all the time
over and over again
in contrast transcripts with a
regulatory role such as transcription
factors or cell cycle genes tend to
decay faster more certainly because
control of the persistence of genetic
information facilitates adaptation to
environmental changes so that means of
an external stimuli these regulatory
genes must be turned off rapidly and and
this is implemented at the RNA level by
having intrinsic short half-life lowest
abilities now to further validate slam
seek we performed mechanistic studies on
a specific post transcriptional gene
regulatory pathway with bail establish
biological function in modern extensions
so this end we focused on microarrays
which act as key regulators of gene
expression in a variety of biological
contexts in autumn Bernie's sensor these
micron is contribute to
state maintenance and transitions by
tuning the expression of the SS
transcripts and promoting the clearance
during differentiation at the molecular
level micro rna's act our art of short
run 22 nucleotides non-coding RNAs
direct as guides for ribonucleoprotein
complex is the target complimentary
sites usually within the three prime UTR
of mRNAs now micron is elicited their
function by repressing by the
translation or promoting mRNA DK
although the relative contribution of
repressive modes really remains a matter
of debate and may vary in different
biological contexts now to estimate the
effect of micronus
on mRNA stability in mouse embryonic
stem cells we focused on the micronics
family shown here the mere 291 a family
which share the same c sequence and
target repertoire in represents more
than half of all small rnas expressed in
this Delta as shown in the abundance not
derived from similarity sequencing on
the right corner
so we then investigated we first then
investigated the general Association of
micro RNA targets with mRNA stability
and we found that with a million half of
two point nine hours mRNAs that were
predicted to be targeted by this micron
family in mutant 91 a family and that
means they have a site complementary
through the Micronesian the three prime
UTR were significantly less stable from
in red compared to transcripts that
contain no target site shown in black
which shown average a half F of four
hours
our transcripts with conserve sites sold
iconic binding sites that are conserved
throughout evolution exhibited even
shorter half-lives with a million a set
of two thousand six hours now this is of
course only associative so two confirmed
direct contribution of micron is to
transcript destabilization we determine
changes in
MRNA half life in modern expenses
depleted of the core micron about
Genesis vector exporting spice which was
depleted by Chris because nine genome
engineering when compared to wild-type
cells division of x5 a significantly
decreased overall micron levels by more
than 90% and particularly the mutant 91
a family member members by more than 95%
as determined by spite in normalized
small RNA sequencing now consistent with
a function of microRNAs in triggering
mrna decay we observed a significant
increase in relative mrna stabilities
for targets of me 291 a family when
compared to transcripts containing no
target sites up or depletion of
exporting site now target binding by
micron is primarily mediated via the
so-called seed sequence which
encompasses nucleotides 2 to 7 or 8 when
counted from the micron if I prevent and
it has previously been proposed that the
efficiency of micro RNA mediated gene
regulation can be classified according
to the extent and nature of base pairing
to get further into insight into this we
inspected the efficacy of four different
site types 6 mere sites 7 male with an a
across position 1 7 l with a match and
position 8 and 8 min sites and
investigated the effect on mRNA
destabilization while a each site type
responded to expert in five depletion
with a significant increase in mRNA
stability relative to untargeted
transcripts
6 massage clearly shows the weakest
effect followed by the truth 7 mere site
types and 8 male sites showed strongest
the repression confirming that
classification of my chronic site types
translates into the pathological
efficacy of my chronic and it highlights
the accuracy which slams the protocols
in able to measure even by nu
differences in mRNA stability our
summary these data provide a
quantitative
evidence for micron immediated mrna
decay in mouse embryonic stem cells and
Belly days slam cheek as a sensitive
tool to study the molecular basis
underlying the fine tuning of mRNA
expression levels by micro neighs and
therefore more generally the mechanisms
underlying post inscription and gene
regulation
now with this I would like to come to
the summary of today's presentation so
I've introduced you today to novel
high-throughput sequencing methods or
the global metabolic sequencing of RNA
which were referred to as styling
technique addition for the metabolic
sequencing of RNA or slanty cleansing is
an orthogonal chemistry based sequencing
protocol that uncovers for tolerating
incorporation in artists Isha's at
single nucleotide resolution and close
to absolute circulatory in the context
of an latest RNA now when color to
well-established fourth I you metabolic
labeling protocols in cultured cells and
capital mRNA three permanent sequencing
slam stick enables rapid access to gene
expression dynamics in living cells and
unprecedented accessibility efficiency
and scalability while the Memphis is in
principle a principle
compatible with any RNA library
preparation method that involves cDNA
conversion I've shown you that coupling
it to M only three prevents sequencing
where the quality approach provides some
key advantages in building that it's
samples polyadenylated RNA species in
the context of total RNA it provides
further insight into three prime either
form specific expression dynamics
facilitates thematic analysis due to
molecular counting approaches and it it
has the key advantage of producing
highly reproducible
gene expression profiling libraries
through a rapid work so in principle
this approach can also be applied with
very low input materials down to a
hundred picogram although we have
standards used 500 nano grammars input
materials i think it's worth to mention
the
in many of the experimental set up the
material input materials actually
limiting what we think that this
approach is covering this aspect so
either biological side I've shown you
some of the applications of slam seek on
the one side I shown you that short for
Toyota's labeling followed by slam seek
enables to measure functional process or
nipple to directed transcriptional
output unqualified transcriptional gene
regulation is confirmed by mechanistic
studies on enhance the functioning of
embryonic stem cells and I've also shown
you that a four-tire pulse labeling
followed by wash outs and chase
experimental setup enables to directly
measure genome-wide transcript abilities
in order to detect the molecular basis
for post transcriptional gene regulation
as exemplified but a function of
microRNAs which mediates site type
dependent transcript destabilization in
mouse embryonic stem cells now the work
the people involved in this work i've
already highlighted in the beginning
once again is it's mostly led by a great
postdoc in the lateral again here so
supported by two PhD students Brian
rifles and which are bus
we had great collaborations here at the
Vienna bio center with your stupid lab
and Anthony's alert lab maybe the
balanced annotations who continue to and
rapid pipeline that can that facilitates
the analysis of Lambs equally as Nolan
and the depression neither the work
benefits enormously from outstanding
service facilitates the facilities at in
by and the piano biases and would like
to particularly highlight the
exceptional available career
opportunities here on campus especially
the international DBT ph.d program in
work of this project was funded by the
European Research Council and the
Austrian science fund so at the end I
would like to briefly mention this
listing is a licensed technology that is
commercially available from oxygen they
provide tips that facilitate the set up
of plenty
to Atlantic Explorer filtering through
the cell viability titration module for
setting for time toxicity in target cell
lines in a for dialing corporation
module to measure for Taiyo uptake and
in cooperation integrate using HPLC and
again we highly recommend to perform
inside this control experiments because
of reasons that I mentioned in the talk
and they also provide learners be
connecticut's that enable anabolic on
the one set anabolic labeling
experiments which label newly
transcribed RNA with both iuen measure
nets and RNA expression to analyze RNA
synthesis kinetics and catabolic kids on
the other side that lasers existing RNAs
in order to access transcript stability
for the analysis of already degradation
kinetics and finally for the rapid
bioinformatics analysis the slam seek
data sets of authentic datasets we have
developed in collaboration as I
mentioned with to be is normally a
depression here a bass-o-matic pipeline
called
digital and marketing of nucleotide
conversion containing k-mers or dunk
which a slam dunk has been included on
Ruby
cloud-based platform and is accessible
with a special code of italics agenda so
this I would like to thank you very much
for your attention and I would be happy
to answer any questions thank you for
that informative presentation before we
get started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window or try
to answer as many questions as we can
dr. stephan Amira's is now joined by the
oxygen application scientist dr.
Stephanie banister to answer your
questions about the slam seat technology
and the kids and our first question is
the slam seek work well across different
cell culture types for example primary
neuronal culture and that would be
flight difference yes so
we have tried multiple different
centimes meanwhile and we find that in
average across different mammalian
setups that we've tested we find that
all of them do take up for thigh or
edema but they do so to varying degree
so I think it is very wise to start an
Atlantic experiment by just testing for
tie you up take by first measuring
toxicity and and and using for example
the single nucleotide chess chilli an
HPLC approach from total RNA which
doesn't require basically a lot of time
and effort to investigate whether forth
IU is taken up and incorporated into the
newly transcribed RNA in the cell type
that is studied so this is an setup that
can be found also in our fabrication I
think that and is available through the
neck surgeon that I would definitely
recommend before starting an Atlantic
experiment in a normal cell that has not
previously been carefully assessed for
its ability to take up and incorporate
photon you reading but overall I am very
positive so we haven't seen dramatic
outliers so far so sedatives that are
not at all taking up for value reading
as on this next one is for you to for
human cells for example hep to 93 or
Gila to what depth would you need to
sequence if using a short for if you
pulse around 10 minutes given that there
is no enrichment for labeled RNA which
would be a small fraction of the total
RNA so there is a very good question so
this is so I mentioned that how athletic
encompassing the transcribed RNA is that
it does this in a context of unlabeled
RNA species which is an advantage on the
one side and there and disadvantage on
the other side because it is short
translating an approach is of course a
very small fraction will be labeled but
we've done of various
there's experiments using short path
labeling and in average and good
approximation for the sequencing depth
is the American sequence up to three
multiplex samples in one lane of single
reads hundred on an Illumina high-tech
2007 a platform for example that will
enable to analyze transcriptional output
of thousands of genes so that's an
approximation that I can give but of
course again also in this experimental
setup I would recommend to optimize for
tile labeling conditions by using
maximum tolerated amount of value which
will of course also facilitate then in
particularly in chiapas labeling
approaches the ability to uncover de
novo transcribed transcripts upon one of
the future of metabolic RNA labeling in
vivo cancel and seek or similar methods
be tweaked for in vivo that is a very
good question so and they are of course
approaches going on to try to implement
slam seek in similar producing people
metabolic labeling in vivo can be
achieved so that it have shown that for
value can be injected in animals and
even using a specific end time the
converse with something uracil and you
regime need to called you care t1 can
perform tissue specific labeling of RNA
so and labeling is possible in vivo
whether kinetic gene expression analysis
as opposed to the simple tissue specific
gene expression analysis is really
possible
depends on pharmacokinetics of water use
so how rapidly does actually a given
cell type take up for tae Jordan and to
try these experiments who really get to
to gene expression dynamics in vivo will
be challenging in future this next one
is for you to I would like to know the
cell line that you have used and the
for su incorporation in your total RNA
thanks in so the percentage of portable
if I understood that correctly the
percentage of for tile incorporation so
will again depend on the labeling
efficiency so what we have determined is
we have compared after saturation
labeling basically how many transcripts
that incorporate the fourth IU we can
actually uncover and for this we have
basically compared a poly a pulldown and
mass spectrometry which estimate gives
one estimate of how many of both I use
are replaced by Jordan and landing on
the other side which keep basically both
of the same results which is there in
multi mimic stem cells every sportiest
nucleotide photo every photos you
reading story is replaced by us what are
you T and when one translates that to N
or D 3 Prime and sequencing using the
Quantic approach for example then and
what uses singles with hundreds then
this would enable to recover more than
70 percent of all of all later
transcripts so a significant fraction of
later transcripts it's directly measured
through through this approach by a
throughput sequencing I hope this
answers the question definitely this
next one is for you what kids do I need
to purchase for my first experiment with
slam chic thanks Judy so as Stefan just
mentioned the ideal way to start over
some sticky experiment especially when
using a new cell type or with a
different labeling approach labeling
duration for a different experimental
setups is to start with the slam seek
explorer kits so we have two modules
from the slam seek explorer kit the
first one is the cell viability
titration module and this allows you to
assess the s for you for failure attain
toxicity in the target cell line that
you're working with and this provides
all of the labeling is for you reagent
and allows you to optimize those
labeling concentrations for your
kinetics experiments and then once you
have established the cell titration
toxicity level you can go ahead with the
f4u incorporation module which is the
other Explorer kit and this allows you
to measure the f4u uptake and the
incorporation rates using the HPLC
analysis method that Stephan has
described and once you have these two
parameters in place so you know the
optimal concentration for your labeling
experiments and this allows you to
understand incorporation rate and sort
of the labeling percentage in your
samples then you can proceed with
kinetics experiments so we have two kits
available for kinetics experiments the
first is the antibiotic anabolic
kinetics kit so this allows you to label
nearly transcribed or nascent RNA with
for failure 18 it provides the odo
acetamide for the alkylation step and
allows you to perform kinetics
experiments to help you look at RNA
synthesis kinetics and then if you're
interested in mRNA degradation or mRNA
half-life then we would recommend the
catabolic kinetics kit this one allows
you to perform an extended labeling
using if for failure 18 for your RNA and
then to replace this with unlabeled
uridine and then sample over a time
course which will allow you to assess
the transcript stability and analyze RNA
degradation kinetics so this anabolic
and connect anabolic and catabolic
kinetics keeps both provide the ayodhya
acetamide for the alkylation in addition
they provide reagents that help to
stabilize the RNA extraction process so
with with the culmination of these
landscape kids you can prepare your
total RNA through the alkylation
reaction ready for library preparation
especially this next one is for you to
what is the advantage of SLAM sequel or
other methods utilizing forced bio
Jurgen I see the primary advantage with
slam seek over these other methods is
that you don't need to perform any
biochemical pull down which Stephan
alluded to at the beginning of his
presentation so instead of needing high
inputs of RNA in the high microgram
range your
need low amounts of input RNA in the low
microgram or nanogram range and these
can be obtained easily from cultured
cells following the slim seek labeling
and then the simple alkylation reaction
means that you can also generate your
sequencing libraries from a single RNA
sample where you can look at the labeled
nascent RNA fraction and the existing
RNA fraction in one library without
having to perform separate library prep
ok and this next one is for you - can I
use only Quantic library prep with slam
seek or other library prep methods can
also be used what is the advantage of
using quantity so this is a really great
question I think there were a couple of
other questions that came up in regards
to this so Quantic is a really ideal
library prep method for slams
experiments the one of the main
advantages here is that your profiling
3-prime tags from full-length mRNAs so
that you know these mRNAs are coding for
fully functional proteins and the other
advantage for a quant seek is that you
only need one tenth of the read depth
that you would need for a usual mRNA
sequencing experiment
so this means that you can multiplex
more samples together although you might
need a high amount of recounts in the 20
to 30 million read range if you're
looking at these short time course time
points this is still going to provide
you with a significant advantage over a
traditional mRNA see quare you may need
up to 100 million reads and that in
principle this one cig method itself is
for preparation of total RNA ready for
RNA seek library prep so in case you
were looking at non polyadenylated
transcripts or wanted to have resolution
of isoforms and sequence other parts of
the mRNA transcripts then it is possible
to use these prime seek generated total
RNA for other library prep methods let
me why when you pulse 24 hours do you
change the media every 3 hours so the
the idea with changing the media every 3
hours is
to ensure that the for failure Dean is
remaining fresh and non oxidized form so
the stability can decrease over time and
that's why we recommend to replace the
media every three hours and this will
ensure that the supplier for failure
Dean is fresh to the cells that this can
be incorporated in its fully functional
state so that it can be efficiently
alkylated next month for you - hi are
there any commercially available
spikings that are compatible with three
prime and quad cheek so the answer is
yes at lexington we've actually designed
our own set of RNA spiking variant
controls called serves so these are a
set of 69 artificial transcripts that
actually represent isoform complexity so
while trance Quantic itself is not a
library prep method that is designed to
capture the comprehensive transcript
isoform identity these isoforms all have
a poly a tail so these allow you to
spike this into your quant seek
experiment and those will be generated
libraries will be generated from these
serve transcripts alongside your
endogenous transcripts and we provide
service wheat which allows you to
analyze the recounts that assigned to
these serve spiking transcripts and this
will allow you to generate a measure
foot a fingerprint essentially of the
spiking controls in your sample so you
can choose the spike in level we
recommend recommend spiking these in at
1% and this allows you to assess the
technical constraints of your library
preparation we actually provide these
circles in three different mixes one mix
is our mix one and these actually
provides three tubes of serves and in
the three tubes who have different equal
molar mixes of some of these serve ice
forms which means you can assess not
only the iPhone complexity but also the
the dynamic range we have a second mix
which contains just an equal molar mix
of the 69 serve and our third serve sets
three contains 60
artificial serve isoforms plus b92
er CC spiking controls which also
contain a poly a tail and we actually
recommend the service set 3 which
contains both the serve isoforms and the
ER CC spiking controls because this
gives you a maximum number of baikin
transcripts available for benchmarking
and control of your rna-seq experiments
Thank You Stephanie's next one is for
you could the conversion chemistry as
for you alkylation be used with an RNA
library prep method that does not offer
that does allow discrimination between
MRA
isoforms and non poly a RNA in principle
yes is possible so in principle slam
streak is compatible with any any
library prep method that involves
conversion into cDNA so we get ok
missteps will appear to cancel and seek
be used to quantify non-coding RNA this
goes in a similar direction again if one
has proper sequencing strategies or
library preparation protocol then yes
in this emboss and reverse transcription
step then yes it should be compatible
with quantifying non-coding RNAs ok and
I believe more questions are coming in
but I think in the meantime it might be
best if we if we share some closing
comments and we can always take them you
know a little bit later I would like to
once again thank dr. Ramirez for his
presentation do you have any final
comment No thank you very much for
listening
hey I would also like to thank our
sponsor Lexington for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through May 2018 you'll receive
an email from lab roots alerting the
women's webcast to be available for
replay only invite you to afford then
announcements your colleagues who may
have missed today's live event we will
see you next time goodbye